dimanche matin quelle idée ou d'aller
tourner des vidéos un dimanche matin
salut c'est monsieur bré aujourd'hui on
va parler d'un drone aquatique alors
saint sozy vous et gardez quelques temps
dans les cartons j'ai rencontré la
société la société comment il s'appelle
la société cas ici technologie aux crs à
las vegas en janvier cette année et il
développe un drone aquatique alors les
drôles on connaît les drôles dans le
ciel qui vole trop que télécommande et
il ya toutes les sortes de toutes les
marques
même si la référence grand public reste
dj hi il y en a énormément mais des
drones aquatique
jusqu'à présent il y en avait pas ou en
tout cas pas à ma connaissance là pour
qu ils travaillent sur un groupe qui
s'appelle le fish p3 syndrome que vous
télécommande est tout simplement qui est
sous l'eau qui a pouvoir filmer les
pouvoirs vous balader sous l'eau faire
des plantes a pas mal de choses et c'est
super intéressant c'est ça que je
voulais partager avec vous alors je n'ai
pas le partage est forcément tout de
suite tout de suite au match janvier
parce que aller sous l'eau ma journée
c'est un petit peu prendra pas trop
envie mais la météo des beaux jours
arrivent et que l'été se profile ça peut
être intéressant
on va retourner aux crs on va les voir
ça alors à titre d'information ce drone
pas forcément destiné à tout le monde
plutôt pro qu'au grand public sauf si
effectivement vous avez envie d'investir
son contrat le prix 3000 $ pour drones
là on peut retrouver sur indy gogo et
sur une digue au bouddha des tarifs
vraiment très intéressant ton petit
complet qui dresse devant la peu
présents autour des 4582 dollar
vous pouvez l'acheter en précommande à
1999 dollars faut savoir qu'ils ont déjà
atteint leur palier max max max depuis
longtemps sur inigo gogh mais pour
l'instant c'est encore disponibles alors
on y va on part au csc on y va
oui
[Musique]
un peu
là on est au c es devant un stand qui a
un produit je pense qu'il peut vous
intéresser
c'est un drône aquatique alors vous me
direz les drones ça va dans l'air sahara
ce taux est bas celui ci va sous l'eau
alors c'est un drone qui est plus dédié
aux professionnels qu'aux particuliers
mais qui est vraiment été un hyper
intéressant et en tout cas il montre on
va pouvoir envoyer des drones sous l'eau
s'amuser on peut l'imaginer dans pleins
d'applications différentes soirées
piscine des bassins et pourquoi pas dans
la mer alors je vous explique
[Musique]
pour l'instant il est relié encore avec
un cap mais on imagine que dans les
temps à venir
c'est des choses qui vont vraiment
évolué c'est un drôle qui paye dans une
profondeur jusqu'à 100 m donc ça laisse
quand même un peu de marge il a deux
phares à l'avant pour éclairer enfin
vous puissiez voir un petit peu ce qui
se passe dans les profondeurs parce que
dès qu'on se sent forcément ça vous en
doutez il ya quand même beaucoup moins
lumière une caméra qui est une ouverture
de 2.8 et de toute façon lorsque vous
allumez la lumière voilà quand même vous
éclairer ce qui se passe donc en termes
de luminosité
sadry franchement allez vous pouvez
filmer une résolution maximale de 4 car
ça c'est plutôt pas mal parce que pour
se faire des souvenirs sous l'eau filmer
des poissons filets ce que vous voulez
et pourquoi pas vos vacances
elle vous filmer en train de plonger
c'est vraiment un art ça pourrait faire
une expérience complètement fabuleuse
vous pouvez le laisser sous l'eau
jusqu'à deux heures deux heures sous
l'eau et vous avez bien sûr une
transmission en temps réel directement
sur votre télécommande
ce qui fait que vous voyez est
exactement ce qui se passe ça vous
transmet directement comme un drone
aérien
donc voila un petit peu l'idée alors
effectivement ce n'est pas un produit
qu'on va retrouver tout de suite pour le
grand public c'est plus un produit comme
je disais qu'est dédié aux
professionnels mais ce que ça montre
c'est que l'univers du drone n'arrête
pas de n'arrête pas d'évoluer
on va pouvoir je pense dans les années à
venir retrouvez ce genre de produit pour
le marché grand public
c'est hyper prometteur c'est hyper
intéressant moi je pense en tout cas
hyper sexy c'est pas vous ce que vous en
pensez
est ce que vous trouvez que ce petit
drone aquatique est intéressant est ce
que vous pourriez imaginer acheter ce
genre de choses que vous partiez en
vacances ou à une piscine
pour énormément d'applications mettez
moi tout ça en commentaire parce que ce
truc je trouve cool trouve hyper sexy
c'est vraiment sympa et on peut comme je
vous le dis imaginez énormément de
choses
merci d'avoir donné cette vidéo je vous
invite comme d'habitude on essaye de
jolis pousse à vous abonner
on reste connectés parce qu'on va parler
toujours plus et énormément de produits
tech ai vu des choses de dingue c est ce
qu on va continuer par la suite parce
capable de crs
il ya d'autres salons qui vont arriver
il ya d'autres nouveautés il ya plein de
choses donc restez connectés on reste
ensemble
n'oubliez pas de vous aime vous dis à
très bientôt ciao
[Musique]